hi my name is kanchan koya as the
founder of spice spice baby with a phd
in biomedicine i know that food can be
medicine what we eat plays a huge role
in our overall health so today i'm going
to show you how to make a gut health
boosting dinner and dessert that is as
good for you as it is delicious let's
get started
when we think about gut health we're
really thinking about the health of our
microbiome the microbiome is the
trillions of bacteria that live in our
guts these bacteria can be good
beneficial bacteria that do tremendously
useful things for our health if we feed
them the right foods
we're going to start with whole
coriander seeds when we're thinking
about gut health we also want to think
about managing inflammation and all of
the spices in this marinade are
inflammation fighters when you toast
these whole coriander seeds you're
waking up a lot of those beneficial
volatile compounds and now we're gonna
tip them into the mortar and pestle and
grind them up grinding whole spices up
to dry toasting them is the best way to
not just get the health benefits out of
the spice but also to get massive flavor
these ground coriander seeds are going
to give you these magical citrusy
peppery notes with a little bit of
crunch we're going to tip them into the
marinade for our salmon i'm adding olive
oil turmeric cinnamon cayenne pepper
garlic ginger and cumin i'm also adding
salt and pepper to taste all of these
spices not just boot gut health and
favorably interact with the microbiome
but they also fight inflammation this is
a marinade you can make and put on
anything i would put it on toast because
i'm the spice mama but you could put it
on chicken roast vegetables really
anything we're just gonna spoon this
marinade over our salmon salmon is
amazing for gut health because of the
omega-3 fatty acids found in salmon and
other types of fish these omega-3 fats
are also inflammation fighters and
studies have shown that salmon can
increase the diversity of the bugs in
our microbiome really nourishing the
good guys and keeping in check the not
so good ones hands down the most
effective way to nourish your microbiome
is to eat lots and lots of plant-based
foods like fruits vegetables legumes
lentils this is why we are adding
oranges and lemons to add not just gut
health boosting fiber but also
really delicious taste notes
[Music]
the easiest way to think of your gut
microbiome in health is to think of jedi
bugs and stormtrooper bugs the jedis
they're the good guys they keep you
healthy they fight off the storm
troopers and the stormtroopers well we
know what they do so
a great way to boost the jedi bugs is to
feed them foods that they love this
brings us to the dandelion greens which
we're cooking up today these greens
contain prebiotics which are food for
the probiotics so they really help those
jedi bacteria become strong and powerful
we're going to start with some olive oil
in a pan on medium heat to this olive
oil we're adding some onion
we're going to allow it to soften for a
few minutes the onion olive oil garlic
and lemon is really going to help to
counter those bitter notes in the
dandelion greens we're going to add the
garlic and just allow it to get fragrant
for about a minute we don't want to burn
the garlic we just want it to soften and
mellow out a great hack to extract the
maximum benefits from garlic is to chop
the garlic and let it sit for about 10
minutes before you add it to your dish
because this will allow allicin which is
a powerful anti-inflammatory compound to
get truly activated to the onion and
garlic we're going to add our gorgeous
dandelion greens
dandelion greens are particularly
powerful gut health boosting foods
because they contain a fiber called
inulin which is one of the most potent
prebiotic fibers out there okay they're
wilting beautifully and so we're just
gonna hit them with a little salt a
little pepper
and a generous squeeze of lemon juice
the lemon is not just going to help with
flavor but it's also going to help you
extract lots of micronutrients from the
greens okay
that is looking good we're going to
check on our salmon and complete our
dinner now that everything's done we
have our salmon we have our dandelion
greens and we've also plated it with our
sweet potato fries because plants fiber
color all going to benefit your gut
health okay so plating oh my god that
actually looks really good when using
salmon it's a really good idea when you
can to go with wild caught salmon over
farm salmon because not only is it
richer in omega-3 fats but it's also
lower in some organic pollutants this is
looking beautiful but we're not quite
finished we're gonna top this with some
more gut health boosting goodness first
up we have fresh cilantro just like we
have the coriander seeds we now have
fresh cilantro which has gut health
boosting antioxidant properties as well
next up sumac one of my favorite spices
of all time think of it as lemon without
the liquid
also powerful anti-inflammatory spice
and antioxidant rich spice and last but
not least the king of all gut health
boosting foods broccoli sprouts broccoli
sprouts contain a compound called
sulforaphane which is nature's most
powerful activator of anti-inflammatory
pathways in our body and also
antioxidants if you can't get your hand
on broccoli sprouts you could just
incorporate raw broccoli on a regular
basis in your diet we're just gonna top
our salmon with these anti-inflammatory
gut health boosting broccoli sprouts
which are also gonna give you this
mustardy peppery flavor after this we're
gonna get started with dessert where
we're gonna be cooking our spiced apple
crumble this dessert packs a bunch of
those beneficial prebiotic fibers to
boost the good bacteria and it's super
delicious in the bowl we have oat flour
which is a really good substitute for
all-purpose white flour because it has
much more of those gut health boosting
fibers to that we're going to add ginger
cardamom another potent gut health
boosting spice cinnamon for
anti-inflammatory and gut health
boosting effects and a pinch of salt
then i'm just gonna mix this in to
incorporate all those spices into the
flour and now we're gonna go in with
cubed cold butter you could use a wooden
spoon to mix this in but i just find
good clean hands to be really efficient
you're just going to break up these
cubes of butter and integrate the butter
with the flour until it's relatively
smooth next in we're going in with some
coconut sugar and now we're adding our
rolled oats
oats contain another really beneficial
prebiotic fiber called beta glucan
which you guessed it feeds the good bugs
now that we're done with our crumble we
can move on to our apples while all
fruits and vegetables are going to give
you those beneficial fibers for optimal
gut microbiome health apples really come
out on top because of a particular kind
of fiber called pectin which really
nourishes the beneficial bugs in our
guts we're going to need six cups of
apples so we're just gonna cut this
discard the core and chop it up
we're just gonna drizzle some vanilla
extract on these apples give them a nice
toss
now that we've tossed the apples with
the vanilla we're gonna add them to our
baking dish and now we're going in with
that whole grain infused oat spiced
crumble
that's just gonna melt
over that fruit into a buttery goodness
that's gonna be so
yummy you just wanna spread the crumble
topping as evenly as possible over the
fruit it doesn't have to be perfect
[Music]
the crumble is golden brown and done we
are going gonna start plating
this is a dessert you can really feel
good about from all that fiber from the
oats the apples and those
anti-inflammatory spices and we're just
gonna top it with a dollop of coconut
yogurt
so there we have it our spiced salmon
with the citrus sumac and broccoli
sprouts are crumbled with cardamom
cinnamon and coconut yogurt
so often we think healthy meals have to
be boring and uninspiring and i hope i
have encouraged you to make yourself a
healthy and delicious gut health
boosting meal today if you want to see
more meals like this let us know in the
comments below i'm kanchan koya thanks
so much for watching oh yes
[Music]